faustan is jam-packed with big names but
one of the biggest names in Hollywood is
conspicuously absent and fans of the
fast family aren't feeling it on
February 10th the first trailer for the
10th Fast and Furious franchise film
fast 10 hit the internet sparking plenty
of excitement among the series
ever-growing fan base fast movies are
big by their very nature but there are a
few reasons to believe that fast 10 will
be the franchise's biggest entry yet
including this first trailer's runtime
clocking in at roughly three and a half
minutes in total perhaps the clearest
indicator of the considerable scale of
fast 10 is its out of control budget
Midway through its production news broke
that fast 10 had already cost producers
340 million dollars beating out the
budget of the previous film by 140
million dollars one of the key
contributors to this outsized amount of
money is it's absolutely stacked cast
game recognizes game absent from that
all-star cast however is Dwayne The Rock
Johnson whose character Luke Hobbs
joined the team in Fast Five before
eventually separating from the mainline
series for spin-off Fast and Furious
presents Hobbes and Shaw while Johnson's
unique trajectory through the franchise
is well documented some fans are
nevertheless noting his absence from the
first fast 10 trailer on YouTube plenty
of commenters responded to the fast 10
trailer with excitement about its
expansive cast featuring nearly every
big name from the franchise's history
however some users argued that only with
the addition of Johnson could its cast
truly be comprehensive
never be able to break my family in a
Reddit discussion Thread about the
trailer a few commenters also described
Johnson's absence as a detriment to an
otherwise promising preview for the film
for instance one user wrote this looks
great but it's missing something without
Dwayne in my opinion another user then
replied that Johnson's Luke Hobbs seems
to be the only major character that's
not a part of the fast 10 cast plenty of
Twitter users are discussing the lack of
Johnson in fast 10 as well one user with
Johnson in their avatar for example
shared that they feel the inclusion of
Jason Statham's Deckard Shaw makes
Johnson's absence particularly unusual
another user even argued that Hobbs
should appear in fast 10 for plot
reasons given that he had a hand in
killing Jason momoa's character Dante's
father by now Johnson's reasons for
exiting the mainline fast franchise are
well known among fans of the series a
July 2021 profile of Johnson in The
Hollywood Reporter for example recounts
how Vin Diesel claimed the Discord
between the two actors resulted from his
attempts at eliciting a stronger
performance from Johnson he told the
outlet I laughed and I laughed hard I
think everyone had a laugh at that I
wish them the best of luck on fast 10
and fast 11 and the rest of the Fast and
Furious movies they do that will be
without me then as recently as November
of 2021 diesel introduced a new
complication to his Feud with Johnson
when he praised his former co-star and
encouraged him to join fast 10 Anew in
response Johnson shared that he felt
manipulated particularly by the fact
that diesel invoked both his children
and the memory of Paul Walker Johnson
also revealed that he had privately
communicated to diesel his desire to
separate himself from the fast franchise
in no uncertain terms a few months prior
from the sound of it then diesel agrees
with fans who have argued that fast 10
is incomplete without Johnson meanwhile
Johnson appears to remain committed to
separating himself from the fast films
and diesel in particular for as long as
the series continues
foreign